it's totally unbearable it's against
international law and it is of course
inhuman brutal this is what the
Palestinian people experienced every day
for the last 15 years I've been working
as a medical solidarity worker in Gaza
mostly at Al Shifa Hospital which is the
trauma center in Gaza and I have been a
chief hospital during the last four
Israeli attacks on Gaza the private
sector is in ruin because the Israelis
have bombed so many factories so many
production plants and of course only one
percent of the needed building material
to reconstruct the civilian society has
been allowed through the fence through
the walls
meaning that through these four attacks
Israeli government and trailer army has
has totally smoldered totally destroyed
all the fundamental preconditions for
Public Health
the most graphic moment during the last
attack this a Shia attack when Israeli
army founded the suburban era of a Shia
throughout the night hundreds of people
were killed thousands were injured that
night all day Schieffer received around
400 people and he did medical attention
it was nightmarish I think what what we
don't realize is how extremely brutal
the suffocation of the people of Gaza is
the main health problem in Gaza today is
the siege of Gaza the foundation of
public health is access to water food
human security work housing education
sanitation and then comes to health care
if you don't have these first provisions
in place then you cannot produce public
health in Gaza all these provisions are
deficient it should appeal to all of us
it should make all of us stand up and
say we don't want this we don't want
walls in this world today we don't want
apartheid in this world today and the
treatment of the Palestinian people is
the most graphic illustration of an
apartheid system that you can think of
so here's my prescription
lift the siege immediately stop the
bombing and the occupation find a
peaceful just solution for the
Palestinian people and end Israeli
Zionist apartheid